All right, guys.
He's doing it.
He is doing it.
Donald Trump and his CDC have sent out a letter
to states saying be ready to start distributing
a corona virus vaccine in early November or
late October.
We can read that as before Election Day.
OK.
Do not mistake this for anything other than
what it is.
This is exactly what I predicted was going
to happen.
I told you months ago.
The ideal October surprise for Donald Trump
is going to be the big heroic announcement
of a corona virus vaccine, even if it's not
actually done being tested yet, even if it
won't actually be available to almost anybody
until 2021.
That is going to be Trump's gambit.
That is going to be Trump's October surprise
to try to win the election.
And indeed, as The New York Times is reporting,
the CDC has sent a letter outlining to state
public health officials how they need to prepare
for what Donald Trump is saying is going to
be a vaccine in late October or early November.
The CDC has notified all 50 states and five
large cities to be ready to distribute a corona
virus vaccine to health care workers right
away.
Subsequently to other people in high risk
groups as soon as late October or early November.
Now, over the last week, we've heard from
Anthony Foushee and Steven Hahn from the FDA
who said that it is conceivable, it is conceivable
that you could make a vaccine available before
the phase three clinical trials have been
completed.
If the early data is overwhelmingly positive,
we have the letter from the FDA.
Let's look at it from Dr. Robert Redfield
of the CDC.
It reads, Dated August twenty seventh.
Dear governors, the U.S. Department of Health
and Human Services and CDC are rapidly making
preparations to implement large scale distribution
of Cauvin 19 vaccines in the fall of 2020.
This vaccine distribution program is expected
to be a public health effort of significant
scale, potentially involving hundreds of millions
of vaccine doses to be distributed across
the U.S.. CDC has contracted with McKesson
to distribute these vaccines to state and
local health departments, medical facilities,
doctor offices and other vaccine providers
in order to accomplish this massive task.
McKesson must quickly open new distribution
centers and obtain new permits and licenses.
These applications may be submitted in McKesson's
name or in the name of one of its subsidiaries.
Going on to say, In the near future, the appropriate
state licensing agency will receive permit
applications for the new distribution facilities
going on to say that states should consider
waiving requirements that would prevent these
facilities from being fully operational by
November 1st.
The requirements.
You may be asked to waive in order to expedite
vaccine distribution will not compromise the
safety or integrity of the products being
distributed.
Your assistance in helping expedite the issuance
of licenses and permits required for this
will be critical to the success of this public
health effort to mitigate the threat presented
by Kofod 19.
So why not be more transparent and just say
before November 3rd?
Because that's really what this is about.
Now, I've gotten a lot of emails from from
viewers saying, do you trust the CDC now with
this?
I have no idea.
Certainly, we knew this was what they were
going to go for.
People have been asking me if they approve
a corona virus vaccine with an emergency use
order on October twenty ninth.
Do you go and get in line first for that vaccine?
I think that's the wrong question because
I'm not going to be allowed to be first in
line.
And what I mean by that is there are tens
of thousands of people who are receiving the
vaccine already in phase three trials.
The first availability is going to go, as
they are saying, to health care workers and
to at risk people, older folks, et cetera.
I don't think there's any way I get a vaccine
in 2020, regardless of an emergency youth
use authorization.
That being said, I understand being very suspicious
about the timing of this announcement because
I told you it was going to happen and now
they are planning to do it.
Here's why we should be skeptical or worried
about distributing a vaccine with emergency
use authorization.
First of all, it's never been done before
with a vaccine or at least a major vaccine
that presumably billions of people are going
to want.
We've done emergency use authorizations on
technicalities and we've done emergency use
authorizations on things like hydroxy chloroquine
room desk, severe convalescent plasma.
Now, how well did the hydroxy chloroquine
emergency use authorization go?
Not well at all.
And in fact, that had to be retracted.
So that is because emergency EU ways, as they're
called, involve substandard or lesser reviews
than for full approval.
Are we willing to do that?
With a vaccine, I don't know the answer to
that, but it's definitely something to be
thinking about.
We know E. ways for ventilators, EU, ways
for PPE, maybe for some treatments that appear
to be particularly efficacious.
Okay.
Certainly things to talk about here.
I don't know.
And this is a White House that has brutally
abused its ability to push the FDA to put
out there EU ways.
And some of them, like, for example, with
hydroxy chloroquine, have been revoked because
it was a disastrous idea.
But I am concerned with the political implications
here because Donald Trump is thinking and
it may work.
This is the scary thing.
The idea would be if Donald Trump can announce
a vaccine on October 25th.
And make the case that he had a role in getting
this vaccine out there and buy a role.
I mean, something other than just bullying
the FDA into approving a new way.
OK.
And that that's something he can do just with
raw power.
But what I'm saying is Donald Trump is going
to try to sell Americans on the idea that
we have an approved vaccine, again, through
an EU way earlier than other countries.
Thanks to Trump.
And the reality is any country could skip
steps to get a vaccine approved.
The UK could be dosing people right now if
they had just gone in and said to the about
the Oxford vaccine candidate, let's just approve
it.
And then Oxford vaccine in the UK would say
we got a vaccine early.
We saw what happened in Russia with their
haphazard early approval of a supposed vaccine.
So the gambit is more people will fall for
Trump did it.
Then we'll be skeptical about the politicized
nature of this early emergency use authorization.
I want a vaccine as badly as anybody, but
it's got to be safe.
It's got to be done right.
We have a process for approving vaccines.
Will it work?
Will it work to sway even one percent of the
vote in key states could give the election
to Donald Trump.
Let me know what you think.
We'll be continuing our coverage of this on
The David Pakman Show Instagram page at David
Pakman show while you're there.
I posted a picture this morning of my new
prepping elements to my Instagram David Pakman.
I'm ready for a crisis now.
I just don't know what kind.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.